we're starting to get some major clues  as to when apple's next event is gonna  happen and what exactly we should be  expecting so what i'm gonna do in this  video is break down the new major apple  products that i fully believe are gonna  be coming at that event as well as the  important details you need to know about  those new products the first one we've  got to talk about is the mac mini  packing m1 pro and m1 max chip options  at around  12.99 it's definitely much thinner got a  lot more ports and plexiglass top for  better wireless connectivity i expect  the high-end imac to look almost exactly  like the current 24-inch imac just  bigger it's going to be a 27-inch  display with 120hz pro motion and mini  led technology to start at around 2 000  the m1 pro and m1 max chip options are  guaranteed with one more powerful chip  option which i believe is gonna be the  m1 max duo